[Música]
[Aplausos]
quiere de acá
quisieran ser exitosos levanten la mano
a mano
pero que es serio digan yo quiero ser
exitoso
bueno ahora todos los que levanten la
mano les pregunto
qué es el éxito
yo me crié en una familia de clase media
y al terminar el primario mi mamá con
muchísimo esfuerzo me mandó un colegio
técnico el cual implica 7 años de
secundaria
decía que iba a tener un título iba a
conseguir un buen trabajo
y yo tener un buen sueldo y va a ser
alguien en la vida y va a ser exitoso
cursa el primer año curso el segundo y
al finalizar el tercero tenía que tomar
una decisión
tenía que elegir una especialidad
y me incliné por electromecánica o
programación
y termina entrando electrónica
la electrónica
no es lo mío no me gusta no me llena no
me hace feliz
y si trabajar en algo que no me gusta
durante toda la vida es el precio que
tengo que pagar para ser exitoso
yo no estoy dispuesto a pagarlo
pero es así como la sociedad relaciona
el éxito con la riqueza con la fama con
el poder
y por curiosidad un día decidió buscar
la definición de éxito
y se define como una acción con un
resultado feliz
pensando en esta definición
entiendo que hay tres momentos hay tres
instancias el camino del éxito
el primer momento
como dice la definición hay que buscar
que es eso que nos hace felices que eso
que a mí ezequiel rivero me hace feliz
cuando estaba en tercer año del
secundario yo era un chico tímido e
introvertido
me costaba soltarme con las personas
inseguros
y un día mi mamá volviendo de trabajar
me dice s en el centro me entregaron
este folleto que es de un taller de
teatro
no te digo que vaya a ser actor pero me
comentaron que teatro te halló a
soltarte te ayuda a perder esa timidez
y te ayuda con este tema de la seguridad
fíjate capaz de ayudar
y yo me entusiasmé fui y me anoté
hay una inscripción a la primer cuota
estuve dos meses esperando las clases
eran los sábados a las 9 la mañana y el
día de la primera clase
no voy
me quedé dormido pero si fuera segunda
mitad porque yo quería
y mitad obligado por mi vieja que se
había pagado la inscripción la primer
cuota tenía que ir
y en esa primera en esa segunda clase
nos hicieron realizar ejercicios de
improvisación ejercicios con objetos
ejercicios corporales
y todas estas actividades tenían como
finalidad que perdiéramos la timidez que
perdiéramos ese miedo al ridículo
y el primer año de teatro fue fue con
una terapia empecé a sentirme mejor se
estaba más suelto me sentía mucho más
seguro
el segundo año de teatro yo lo
disfrutaba esperaba toda la semana que
fuera sábado solamente para ir a teatro
y a partir del tercer año
me enamoré
me enamoré porque encontré mi vocación
me enamoré porque entiendo que el teatro
es un juego el teatro de jugar hoy juego
hacer un carnicero mañana juego hacer un
profesor de 1800 pasado como hacer un
pase a su policía
algunos personajes lo hice con mi voz en
otros tuve que modificar la voz
otras personas y baladas
cada personaje tenía un cuerpo se tenía
que probar tenía que experimentar yo
tenía que jugar
y sinceramente no sé qué personaje me va
a tocar ser mañana
sin embargo en este entorno a donde
constantemente cambio de personalidad
es el lugar donde me siento más cómodo
para ser yo mismo
otra cosa que me vuelve loco del teatro
es que no solamente entretener
sino que tener la oportunidad de
transmitir un mensaje transmitir una
idea mostrar mi visión del mundo
el segundo momento la segunda instancia
si retomamos la definición el éxito es
una acción con un resultado feliz
entonces qué es lo que me hace feliz
entonces sé cuál es mi vocación el
teatro ahora tengo que hacer
y actualmente estoy haciendo
estoy generando contenido audiovisual
estoy haciendo grupos para formar una
agrupación teatral estoy haciendo
castings y me estoy equivocando
pero eso no es malo
porque este momento esta instancia
consta de hacer equivocarse aprender y
progresar
yo tenía un director
que se llamaba leo rey
[Música]
y él tenía una frase que a mí me gusta
mucho
equivoquen se en paz
esa frase me quedo marca
porque yo me equivoco
y sin darme cuenta crezco mucho como
actor y sobre todo como persona
y el tercer momento la tercera instancia
no es escalonada no es que el primero el
segundo y el tercer momento sino que
simultánea con las otras dos que
realizamos constantemente que es
alejarnos por un momento de nuestras
vidas y observar nuestro trabajo
realmente me gusta lo que estoy haciendo
realmente este es el camino para llegar
a ese objetivo de lo que me hace feliz
y en esta instancia es donde valoramos
los pequeños progresos esos pequeños
éxitos
yo me siento exitoso
porque se encontré mi vocación
y ustedes me podrían decir que un actor
exitoso es brad pitt johnny depp acá en
argentina ricardo darín
pero no sé si eso es el éxito
mi éxito está en convivir con el teatro
yo descubrí que haciendo teatro soy
feliz
y quizás
terminé trabajando de técnicos
pero la única forma de que eso suceda es
si es parte del personaje de una obra
[Aplausos]
porque eso es encontré mi vocación yo
encontré mi receta del éxito
ahora quisiera preguntarles quién es de
acá se animan
a ser exitosos
[Aplausos]
[Música]